you're about to witness one of the most
bizarre pieces of defensive weaponry
ever devised by mother nature's has
there ever been a weirder use of an eye
socket or of blood
this bloody lizard lives near Saguaro
trees in the Sonoran Desert in Mexico a
bird drops swaro fruit for the harvester
ants to munch up and in turn the Regal
horned lizard munches on the ants the
ants make it their business to fight
back looking for a chink in the lizard's
body armor unfortunately for the ants
the Regal horned lizard has a sticky
tongue with pretty good aim and it's
immune to ant venom and his body can
actually get all the moisture it needs
from the ends which make up 90% of its
diet just as the answer stalked by the
lizard the lizard is stalked by a coyote
the next link on the food chain the
coyote is fast deft and determined
the lizard finally has a reason to
deploy its doomsday weapon that's
swelling below the lizard's eye isn't a
tear duct
it's high-octane coyote repellant aka
blood let er rip blood pressure builds
up to the point where the lizard can
actually shoot blood out of a tie with a
precision aim of a sharpshooter and yes
it's nothing more than plain old blood
the coyote wisely retreats to find a
less feisty meal game set match victory
to the blood squirting Regal horned
lizard